advice exotic pets bill last week I was
laid off from my office cubicle job of
four years I am now a 25 year old
unemployed college student truck
struggling to make rent oh Jesus my
heart goes out to your brother but at
least you're 25 you're not [ __ ]
married you don't have any kids that's
the bright side and I know you don't
need to hear that alright alright here
we go can't go back to my parents as
they are halfway across the planet and
Taiwan now my question is do I continue
to do I continue trying to get back in
the rat race or do I follow my dream of
becoming an exotic pet reptile breeder
Jesus cried a [ __ ] away are you just
[ __ ] with me this is your dream well
you know what you are from Taiwan I
imagine everything that's considered
exotic over here is like nothing you
know I bet over in Taiwan instead of
getting like a bicycle as a
four-year-old they give you like a
defanged Cobra or some [ __ ] I'm sorry I
just had to stop and laugh at the
ignorance of that statement anyways I
have no experience in the field
fantastic
you're gonna be on Spike TV's a thousand
ways to die except okay except that okay
I have no experience in the field except
for that I have a snake and for hamsters
as pets
alright dude I don't want to burst your
bubble but there's nothing exotic about
hamsters even if you have four or cuatro
sorry I started the new [ __ ] rosetta
stone Spanish again hmm yo tengo on
petal its grease egg blanco pero es
bueno is local hey Loco however the [ __ ]
you said my dogs out of it's mine
la mujer I'm on sign of their day
I've been let's get back to this [ __ ] I
think I just said the woman and then
green-apple there's really nothing that
connected either one of us now go [ __ ]
yourself I'm gonna do it some point my
life I'm become bilingual so anyways
this dude wants to start raising exotic
pets breeding them he has no experience
now what kind of [ __ ] snake do you
have you know if you have a garden that
gardener say I guess you got to start
somewhere you do have a reptile and four
little rat thinks this is cool dude you
know what you're doing you're doing like
the open mikes to this I get it you've
got to start slow
you can't start right with the black
mamba I'm gonna get yourself killed
anyways I said I've been to the reptile
expo a couple of times and saw that
vendors they're just breed and sell
snakes for a living and thought to
myself holy [ __ ] I want to do that
encourage animals to bang and sell the
offspring all from my own apartment
living the dream what to do any advice
what gave you the balls to start
stand-up understanding the opportunity
cost of the income of a full-time job
any advice would help thanks mr. burr
alright alright what do you do here well
dude you're doing the right thing you
basically like you you go into one of
those reptile Expos and looking at the
douchebags doing it and being like I
could [ __ ] do that was like me when I
used to watch some of those stand-up
shows and be like I'm funnier than this
guy alright and you have the luxury of
not having a job right now so you don't
have to worry about you know well what
if this interferes with my job you don't
have a [ __ ] job
your biggest thing right now dude is you
need income all right so I would
continue looking for a job that is
flexible alright while you start
building your stockpile of reptiles
first thing I would do is I would go on
the internet and I would read as much as
humanly possible I would go to how to
make two snakes [ __ ] calm I would start
I don't know what to tell you dude I
would just keep going to those Expos
like they're open mics I would keep
reading up on it I would try and find
this is what you do this is what you do
act like you want to buy a [ __ ] snake
and go to some [ __ ] dude and ask them
how they got into the business as you
pretend like you know like you're
browsing and maybe you can get a job
working for one of those guys you figure
out what the [ __ ] he's doing right you
do you pull a Joe Kennedy that I've
learned reading in the wonderful book
the sins of the father yeah that guy
used to work every place he'd work at a
place for like seven months to two years
he'd rifled through all the files get
all this insider information make a
boatload of cash and leave the [ __ ]
company in the [ __ ] okay now I'm not
saying to do that but [ __ ] work with
for these other guys figure out what
they're doing do what they're doing
become better at it that's what I would
do if you really want to do this [ __ ] I
would but uh I got to tell you this man
I don't know how you make two pit vipers
[ __ ] each other but I would definitely
get a I don't know I get a thick pair of
gloves
how do reptiles even get turned on they
just have that [ __ ] look on their
face like you don't know what they're
thinking you know I'd say if snakes had
[ __ ] hands like they would win World
Series of Poker every year there'd be no
[ __ ] way to tell what it had said
holding [ __ ] is it got a full house I
can't [ __ ] just sit there sticking
his tongue on me